hey this is Diplo I'm Dylan Francis
we're gonna be on truth or dab this week
Oh hit him with the slow motion make
sure you check it out
any a magician
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another episode of truth or dab the
hot ones special where we give our
guests two simple options tell the truth
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
today I'm excited to welcome Dylan
Francis and Diplo
you know them as two of the world's most
successful DJs the first half of Dylan's
new mixtape magic is real is available
now lonely alongside the Jonas Brothers
is the latest single from Diplo go check
those out but first the wings of death
fellas welcome to the show thanks for
having us excited to be here I'll say
we're all a bit nervous
I've seen these a couple episodes um we
don't have a lot of spices over my house
so uh but I'm you know you play let's
display the game all right well before
we get started I'll break it down in
front of you you guys have three
scorching hot chicken wings that have
all been doused in various versions of
the last dab I have a set of deeply
personal potentially awkward questions
for each of you and when I ask you a
question you have an option tell the
truth or eat a death wing and Dylan
we'll start with you because you're not
shy about poking fun at EDM culture
whether it's through your character DJ
Hansel are talking about the fan
feedback that makes you roll your eyes
during your house interview with that in
mind what's the most insufferable trend
that you see in the world of EDM right
now bonus points if you can give us the
biggest culprits oh we already just did
it text me here's my number it's
definitely doing I think I think putting
up the numbers of people to text us is
probably the like everyone in even DJ
but like music in general we're all
doing it right now it's like that
annoying trend that's happening all
right diplo to I'm sure that you reach a
certain status as a DJ and you have a
lot of interesting checks that get
dangled in front of you whether it's
like a goofy corporate retreat or some
record executives kids Bar Mitzvah when
you think back in recent history what do
you think is the most shameless bag that
you've taken bonus points if you can
give us a dollar amount
well you know those were DJs our whole
job is like get paid to go DJ a party or
whatever so we have zero shame I'll do
any show there is you know I do I don't
think it's like an embarrassing party or
figure I've done because I've done like
literally like you know shows for free
for kids I've done like bar mitzvahs she
always kind of led to a lot of drugs bar
mitzvahs I didn't know about this a lot
of booths so um yeah I didn't know I
know now my kids are never having a Bar
Mitzvah but uh I'm shameless I'll still
eat a hot wing no [ __ ] up I want to play
this game so we have four more rounds to
go you have three wings okay you know
let's let's play it slow for now all
right so far no wings off the board
Dylan mm-hmm can you rank these
celebrity DJs from best to worst okay
Shaquille O'Neal Paris Hilton Elijah
Wood Lindsay Lohan Elijah Wood DJs you
know he's number one I've never even
seen him but that's tight is the best
one yeah that's the best one
the math is Elijah Wood is a saint he
can do anything he wants and I won't get
mad Lindsay Lohan when the Mykonos yeah
I got like a whole thing a whole thing
over there yeah the Lindsay Lohan
experience well I mean I kind of want to
trade Shack but he's trouble
painting himself into a corner
I mean sure laughs let's go handsome
actually sig DJ Shaq one of craziest DJs
hi this is mine yeah you know well I
mean I Shaq only plays dubstep
I mean plays is like he's agos in the
crowd he's like pictures of every person
and he's like it's true it's actually
the most extreme dubstep I've ever heard
so kudos to him to like it's my whole
life I was getting taken over Elijah
Wood shoutout Lindsay Lohan Shaq then
Paris Hilton parings cool I don't know
but she's still at the bottom I'm sorry
somebody has to be all right through two
rounds here yeah wasn't so far the wing
stone the boys this game
Diplo the DJ magazine top 100 list it
seems to be a list that famous DJs
loathe
and simultaneously cannot stop talking
about oh my god so with that in mind
here we give us your unfiltered thoughts
on the top 100 list there's one problems
if any do you have with this year's top
ten Wow um well I'm not in it I'm gonna
Simon I'm gonna wear you to week you're
not gonna go get it no because I know
all these guys and they're all weirdos
be honest but I actually got banned
Phyllis I thought I told people I pay if
they voted for me I got like bad for
everyone joke but I'm off it so not even
top ten Peter was I didn't get on it
yeah sorry ready I'm ready
right Agee the whole wing yeah you do
all the way down to the holiday they're
all you know there's no place to hide
we're gonna poop my pants you put the
last if in these right yeah a mediator
lace immediate poop your pants
no go around it and go to it there you
go it might be a better idea just to
like take the stick that's ready to go
yeah you're gonna eat the whole thing
that's a good dose that's a good dose
aren't [ __ ] we're halfway through baby
two rounds down three to go
yeah
the hot Dillon yes
which major record label is the biggest
pain in the ass when it comes to
clearing samples or guests versus bonus
points if you can give us a story to
encapsulate that struggle don't let your
mother think I think I think you got our
questions reversed man is that better um
I don't ever think it has to do with the
record label I have thing it mostly has
to do with the artists being a dick or
something like that usually it's like I
think that's the case right
issued wouldn't you say so um I have no
idea just like labels can definitely be
difficult but I think that's more for
like timing stuff you answer the
question really whatever man
[Music]
I'll clean this tournament shout it from
the mountaintops
all right I have this Rose lip balm on
I'll sleep out while you write off you
won't put a record label under the bus
because then you can't actually get any
clearances right make it harder for you
I know that was strategic I was on those
people who but you know who you are I'm
not cleaning those [ __ ] samples so
[ __ ] you let's go Diplo ghost producing
it's a hot-button issue amongst EDM fans
can you out a famous DJ who you think
needs to be called out for practicing
the art of private collaborations more
than most oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna do that
another way okay oh that's good whole
milk on that dip you know is that my all
ten
I'm going to do the whole will dab you
Adam oh I don't know why I eat the whole
thing you're very confident Dylan
it tastes good yeah great sauce thank
you I appreciate I just realized though
that these all say tens on every single
one of them and they are and they are
next question things alright you talk
can you give us a ballpark of your
pre-tax take-home income last year you
know salary transparency it's all the
rage of these two yeah yeah they put it
on top of the other one and they start
having sex in your mouth and that's not
good and there's good but that hurts
your tongue diplo yeah of all the people
that you've annoyed on Twitter over the
years whether it's the Swifty's of the
Burning Man purists yeah
which niche interest group gave you the
most Internet smoke like who would you
know not super far really oh man her
fans are insanity like it's crazy
mm-hmm and you know you're actually the
cool we're friends but like they still
hate me and they still like try to find
ways to like make my life more difficult
so they're organized yeah they're like a
mafia all right fellas we're on to the
last round here round number five and
you each have one wing remaining and
that is great for this little game that
we'll be playing because on Instagram
you guys paint this picture peak BFF
goals from these jet setting vacations
to the quality broad time to executing
secret handshakes and right now we are
going to put those bonds to the test
with a BFF game DOM is coming in with
socks with a pen and paper
so I'll ask the guys ditchin you guys
will write down your answers I don't
think I know how to write anymore so
when we left though and there's only one
wing left because whoever comes out the
other side of this the loser pasty to
death wing to close this thing out all
right are you guys ready for the first
question yeah
what is your BFFs birthday what is your
BFFs birthday so Dylan
you'll write what you think Diplo's
birthday is Diplo you'll write what you
think Dylan's is and whoever comes
closest will win this first round of
three my mouth's on fire dude oh god
sorry a burp on camera all right the
reveal one two three
every day is my BFF Thursday July 4th
that far off because Dylan it's an
October 5th birth yeah for yeah horse it
did it blow your no hunger 10th so after
one round Diplo you're up one zero here
you're up one zero the [ __ ] dude alright
second question name one job your BFF
had before becoming a world famous DJ's
got it a civilian job your BFF had
before becoming a world famous DJ
ah got in my nose and reveal the boy you
got there he was it was Dallas Austin's
assistant and he also worked at that
really cheesy clothing brand
Jay Lindbergh was hundreds but also with
Eric at a o Christian Audigier ed hardy
they worked that Hardy yo back in the
day I knew that he was an English
teacher in Japan alright so here we are
in the final round of these two answers
oh by the way one more to go and this is
a two-parter so you can't actually get
two points for this one so right now
Diplo you're up two to one
alright do this the low yo cuz we both
won that one yep both yeah both got
points there but this third question is
what is your BFFs most watched YouTube
video and how many views does it have I
got it oh [ __ ] I'm a one-hit wonder man
so easy so you're not you guys both have
huge what is that song a Dylan
[ __ ] dude this sucks I hate the show
these wings are way hotter than the ones
on how I noticed it was a second one
Diplo's heiped looks like he's gonna put
a nail in the coffin here the biggest
Diplo song what are we doing 10 B
alright
I thought it was the one in the car like
well you got it you got it won't cut
like a knife resident 18 I couldn't move
it's a terrific cut six Oh someone sex
yeah no you got it I thought if I'm
guessing like this mini lean on I feel
like hit a hundred billion or something
like that right so you are correct there
but 2.6 billion views on Lena and it was
in the bills yeah in your 82 billion
wrong yeah you know what eighty state
billiards the thought that counts this
year but that's a very rare that's a
very rare place to be that 2.6 billion
club not many videos up there what you
missed dip low get low oh [ __ ] hello 602
million views so that actually brings us
to a tie to a tie which I think only
means I'll take this one I'll take it
you don't have to eat that unless you
want no eat it I'm on alright I was
already running like crazy I'll eat that
last one you don't have to all right
we'll split the iron as well there it is
oh that's it that's it hits it's just
hot another truth are dab in the books
Dillon Francis Diplo anything that you'd
like to say to the people before we get
you to an ice bath
go stream my best friend song lonely
with the Jonas Brothers go stream my
mixtape magic is real right now we love
you we'll see you at the next show
EDM lights now we got one we got two I
don't read it you did it no you got
something anybody was read lips right
now I'll nap Kylie Jenner effect are the
odds all three bright you didn't do any
of it leaned my wings bro look at this
sings my coffee alright I'm gonna go
home and cry what is up what is up spice
Lords like and subscribe like and
subscribe
first we feast first we feast like and
subscribe
your to subsume your unique New York
wah-wah-wah-wah like and subscribe
it's camera guy Billy here saying it's
good to be camera guy bill
you
[Music]